so both players getting set up ready to
continue this winners qualifying match I
believe this might be one of our last
top three two qualifiers here yeah this
is our last getting into the
nitty-gritty next size of this I think
will be the top 32 yeah since our last
qualifier we're gonna have thanks
everybody for sticking around and
watching some good matches coming up so
top 32:16 will be out to this then
tomorrow at noon we'll have 1688 and
then top a it's gonna be tomorrow at 6
or 8 I don't know which alright make
sure to tune in though we'll all be
right here on twitch.tv slash dragon
ball fighters yeah so don't you worry
your head I swear this is where you'll
find all the action all weekend long so
you don't need to go anywhere else
just follow this channel yeah the
jackets coming off for only G big focus
Frieza hanker Frieza rolling GT Goku
consulars staples of the meta right now
both very good characters yeah the
reason the back I was talking about
earlier brawly's weird right because
although he's like a big character with
armor and everything
his zoning is one of his biggest merits
right he's a really solid over here
just incredible at spring control right
because of the key blacks because of its
own constraints but it's love fiddle
moment yeah and the super armor yeah are
more to means that like - thinking on in
this kind of reckless right with other
zoning characters don't have those kind
of threats
Mr Wong look or a one overhead brave
lady really watch that mix-up actually
speaking for the double overhead and
going along saw that in the last any
plate as well man yet yeah number one
just like dad's forty seconds yeah super
the tegu tag was like on purpose you
know one of those like early tanks well
you don't know if it was an accident not
wall post there so for a really long
time was fighting fidelity
the war has strikes this blue strange
round start to write both - up block
nothing yeah
couple three for the knockdown
why did he laugh after a super - and did
not need a lab after a super Daddy
I mean I can move like this everybody's
gotta admit you're not the only one yeah
yeah
Manesh for the combo no kill here so all
beautiful fidelity even choosing to spit
the sparking to get the kill now aside
okay you know fidelity with that one oh
man but beli immediately turn around
look to the crowd it was like which one
of you which one of you have y'all sure
that these things y'all should these
things of controllers do you think the
controller CC make a choice right now
and it was during a moment where nobody
could do anything right yes boxes around
stuff oh thank you somebody okay he's
got some rookies man the controller is
preferred to PSA if you don't want this
to happen during your match desync the
control switch right back into the
corner we got some real freaky stuff is
enlarging to semi-coma to dragon laughs
a little finding this gonna space it out
little sparking wouldn't affect it but
actually in that case over with anyway
mr. flack
double reflect even reflected the discs
on the way back to Madrid olives are
they blue - if you changed out right
there that looks low jump sobral ESS is
an ostrich bad right how severe it could
be looking for a raw egg the latest on
telegraphic and high charges the freeze
of jet pile and punches it yeah and this
funny thing of the crowd as soon as that
hit landed just get so like quiet right
like they're obviously changed or
fidelity here gonna get to a stopping
[Music]
spend that life I mean 10 you know at
this point let him move life yeah I mean
it's gonna die in one hit either way now
husband played here again goals low call
who's the boss - this is we saw it start
around with that earlier - yeah I like
that idea
right because you
like clip awesome you know that they're
gonna think okay well he's gonna read
the tag so just go and play swapping
double overhead car cancel out ray-ray
Oh get snatched by up pecking in the
Tian I'll hit away come back grab yeah
using those key blasts super Daffy
so close to getting snack the 2h even
match here I wasn't say race very
cognizant of the key blaster I think
soul cognition they tried to beat it to
the punch with the super - yeah the key
box coming out new scary super - could
it doesn't jump standing out jump in -
yeah but hard to tell the news in the
air and the first day
and definitely not something easy to
recognize the mole 3s purple city Burger
King more time rayray one only yeah I
think fidelity has been really reaching
with the hair close right like either
he's really feeding like to get that one
good snatch and then try to get
something out of it the problem is like
I think when that you're committing to
that a lot it's easy for area to play
around it yes very very good at playing
around Holden so like you take the
massage as well I used to it early head
walk this is from that 5l to oscillate
with a click oh come on that's mr.
button on the ball of them
yeah reflect out good hair - hair - yes
very very you didn't have any Exorcist
or anything so I like that toy actually
that's the Roth IRA ray
[Applause]
back out runs under dry skin or us all
right so doesn't have a negative penalty
from the meter anymore and uh prolly
assist available ice needed the wrong
extension kids in it's gonna be a one
bar kill
first blood to fidelity here really we
saw reraise Kapoor do a lot of work last
time very early
we haven't seen too much of a candy beam
with the Stars some are clawed 805 is
cursing the sky
the news here so you're gonna get it
from the jump page mystic ball no
offense to extend 10 7 out double
reflect
nice instead of using any bar or
banishing or something like that I like
that extension kisses bill versus
pregnancy to go no for always go for all
and fidelity
knowing you had the life we live I got
to get to froggy he's got a strong
soviet-era turnbull he got some good
assists the back of all
- forward - put the delay repledge for a
range great defense
yeah it's way down nice and patient
spent some bar here one three lot of
damage
trying to fake video ran into the low
gets under the keel and I was so sick
using the slide off the end the dunk
beneath the key blast sparked up as well
it's gonna be enough damage here
oh yes it's the blast so Sparky you're
gonna run out here for fidelity just
really big sums ray-bans little juice
parking for a little while now there -
is under it because he knew the momentum
of the staircase is gonna take him over
Wow clash clash with the pure horizontal
boom
I guess I don't make the rules
why else we go the auto crop I'll
actually catch the raw back and it's the
kill most definitely
[Music]
show them the molars dragon rush Oh
but the 6m anyway Old Faithful small a
red outfit this pretty yet talked about
his damage output of course but yet no
Sparky to mitigate some of that life
loss even wage command grabbing to get a
little bit damaged it's a long road
though especially when you don't get the
2h there yeah the wrong tag you would it
to H that we've been a much better
driver position reflects but not reflect
with the whole spring with this boom
again for the set up their chairs
jhump28 to hang in the air pool yeah
even doctor two ages successfully
breeding fidelity right they're losing a
lot of life that's the unfortunate thing
right like and the tax that'll do it one
apiece with the crowd cheering on
fidelity as he ties it up well dump from
the daily bouncing bag only losing one
character that time it's gonna go to
game 3 to see who gets into top 32
yeah what's that early star very
respected the armor success look at it
there oh it's hit by the 5 now put them
in the chest reflect tag is out of there
get the corn I think some baby's not
breathing
quality picks up those Buffalo
successfully man rare it goes well a lot
on these mixers
it really just feels like you know
people are looking out over at option
knee drop connects no problem there's a
moss is this a great way to dogs all
this drug Fidel you click on screen yeah
we've seen a lot of that low slide from
TN so far from reveille he's really been
favoring that quite a bit
reflects the pressure after
we can the dragon rushed over here eight
people hold it up until that point
I'm down here I build that bar you have
to take the trouble they're all
beautiful drag run beats out to reflect
the temp yeah he was this committed to
it in that case right like you know
fidelity happen to be admitting to a
dragon rush
[Music]
[Applause]
three they sorta each
no Big D is and now if you're in that
position riot like what fidelity is if
you get a hit you spark this game's
gonna be very supper rare in a way
I like that he's doing drag erupts like
if it worked twice in a row route on the
road keep committing you know
this coming back reflects some on the
other side of the way we're talking
about experience against Iowa called
earlier place trees with players on the
regular
yeah like fries experience right Wow the
rock Sudoku people fisting ball that's
very surprising I cannot believe that
honestly yeah go somewhere right here
yeah hope the van is she's got to chase
now that's the problem
reflects put it blocks time this is not
where you want to spend your parking
used to eighty all right it's a hint in
sparking this big you know this it's
running out now so you want to try to
get as much damage as possible not a
super effective sparking but a buildable
on a meter and I got him a lot of damage
yeah put them in a spot to kill this
freak a little ball good guard cancer
like they're working the key blaster
[Music]
Fedele do a good job is quicker than the
stickball just popping around and now
he's locked out and does not make the
dragon run
yeah very big the start of some kind of
offense one three
if there's parking here going low and
going or again after making your Blanca
lightning
yeah extension to the kibbutz that's not
easy I feel like that's one of the most
finicky assists the comp off for sure
level one will do it great stuff yeah I
didn't go fidelity was just a little bit
pick it up back by how long he was in
walks line I think he didn't expect the
light you look up through it I did there
snaps out of the air cobble with the
keep laugh-in the vanish go to reach
yeah that was a long long time he is
flying across the screen staggered start
I even looking to confess with a button
of his own locking it out there is
bring them all the way back down
oh that's so good it was so smart he put
him in blocks ton drop them all the way
down ran up and snatched him on the
first commando as we've seen - that's so
cool in that situation where you can
take it you're videoing are how double
jump or air - outright but you really
put up on blocks that with the free zone
while I'm trying to wake up each Larry
and Express
[Applause]
[Music]
set up shop leave the judgment yeah it's
working out I like that choice fly level
three on reaction of course that's all
you're looking for when you're flying
but yeah it's monkeys gonna recover
along a few I can come a bit this should
probably be close level three
and he built it right at the end
fidelity in top 32 in her side for
Puerto Rico taking it too well good
indeed the crowd going